[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARIANNE SLIGHT: --is
integrate both geographic data
so that you can see where the
most prevalent cases of flu
are happening within this
particular region, as well
as additional data sets from
outside of this health system.
These are public
weather data sets
that are available on
top of Google Cloud
Platform for
anybody to integrate
into their clinical or
operational types of analysis.
And so here we're
integrating NOAA weather data
to look at snowfall
and precipitation
and understand how those track
to the different case rates
that we see of flu.
Underneath our Cloud
CDW is Google BigQuery.
And Google BigQuery is an
incredibly powerful managed
database for analytics.
It's a columnar database.
So it works very,
very fast, very,
very efficiently at analyzing
great big chunks of data
and analyzing time
series types of data
that we often see within
the health care space.
It's fully managed,
which means that you
don't need to worry about
the infrastructure for it.
You just go straight to
cloud.google.com/bigquery,
and it's there ready
for you to use.
And it's safer because
we automatically
encrypt all of the data
that's in BigQuery.
And the way that we set
up projects on BigQuery
as part of Cloud CDW enables you
to meet your HIPAA compliance
needs as well.
So we have Deployment
Manager templates
that are set up BigQuery
projects and Google Cloud
projects in a way that helps
you to satisfy your HIPAA
requirements.
In addition, because
we have these public
and commercial data
sets available,
you can integrate these into
the analysis you're doing.
And I'll show you some examples
of those different data sets
as well.
But most powerfully,
it's scalable.
So you can throw
petabytes of data at this,
and it doesn't blink.
Behind the scenes, it
scales up horizontally.
So it's looking ahead at the
analysis you're trying to do,
and just brings
additional machines,
additional compute power to bear
as it sees that you need it.
And interestingly, for
a columnar database,
everything is
queryable through SQL,
which means that we have
a host of different tools
that you can use
on top of BigQuery
directly for doing your
business intelligence
and your visualization.
Google has its own,
Google Data Studio.
But in addition, all
of these different ones
up here are shown as
well, and these all
have direct integrations
into BigQuery.
The dashboard-- we're
in a horror movie today.
Can you tell?
[LAUGHS]
I should just-- thank you.
SPEAKER 1: Hang on.
MARIANNE SLIGHT: Yeah,
the dashboard that you--
oh, we're not up there then.
Well, the dashboard that you saw
before was created with Looker,
but we've also
created dashboards
using Tableau and using
Strategy and others as well.
Thank you.
If you don't mind
staying here and just
wobbling it occasionally.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
MARIANNE SLIGHT: Thank you.
Chief wobbler.
[LAUGHS]
So as you've probably
heard this week,
we've been delighted to
announce that our Healthcare
API has moved to beta.
And what that means is now you
can ingest health care data
into Google Cloud Platform in
its native formats, in FHIR.
Not too many people
yet are using FHIR,
ingesting it
directly in FHIR form
into Google Cloud Platform.
But we're starting to see that
as customers are upgrading
their EMR versions to
the latest versions that
support FHIR interfaces.
Most of the data that we
see coming from EHRs today
comes to us in HL7
version 2 format.
And that's part of the Cloud
Healthcare API as well.
And in addition, we also
support DICOM images.
So any medical radiology
types of image that you have
can also be ingested
natively in this format
directly onto Google
Cloud Platform.
And then what I'm showing
on the right-hand side
is just a simple SQL statement
that's joining EHR and imaging
data together.
And this is the type of
cross modality data analysis
you can do once you've got all
your data together in BigQuery.
So that sounds lovely and easy.
We all know in practice that
every single data source
is different from the next.
And I always like to say
imaging data is nice and large.
It's relatively simple.
EHR data, small and messy.
And so when we think
about harmonizing data,
we think about the
bulk historical data
that you want to bring
into a cloud CDW, as well
as the incremental
or streaming sources
that you're bringing in.
And typically, for your bulk
data, those are in CSV formats,
or it's some kind
of direct connection
through to an external database.
But for incremental data, as
well as those types of source,
it might also be an HL7 version
2 messages, or FHIR messages,
or other types of
streaming data like that.
And what we need to do in
order to harmonize this data
is think about four key aspects.
Harmonizing the field mappings.
So understanding
the source schemas
that you're coming
from, multiple schemas.
What your target schema
is within your cloud CDW.
And I'll talk a little bit
about that in a minute.
And then thinking
about how you map
those schemas, the fields
between them, in order
that when you say patient over
here and path ID over there
and PT ID over there, they
all go to the right patient
ID that you've defined
within BigQuery.
The next area is
terminology mappings,
because we all know
that particularly
when you acquire a new
hospital into your health
system or a new clinic
into your health system,
or maybe because you're
trying to integrate data
from lots of different
sources that are messier,
then different sources use
different terminologies.
Let me give you an example.
I've worked with health systems
where some of the medication
data has been in RxNorm,
but other medication data
has been in FDB, because one
particular hospital relies
on FDB as its
medication vocabulary.
And so understanding
how you convert
between these
different terminologies
is also something
that you need to do
as you harmonize this data.
The next area is around
units alignments.
If any of you have
ever visited a NICU,
you'll know that the weight
of babies, of neonate babies,
is often weighed in
grams, whereas the weight
of the adult patients in other
ICUs within that same health
system is typically measured
in kilos if we're lucky,
or pounds more commonly.
And so aligning the units as
well becomes really important,
not just for things like
math, but also for things
like labs as well.
And then clinical
entity extraction.
I think we've all become very
familiar with physician burnout
and understanding how using--
how physicians like to either
dictate or type up their note.
And so extracting out
the richness of that data
into the structured data,
augmenting the structured data
with the wealth of
information that's
often buried within the clinical
notes from the providers
becomes really important.
Now, today, you can do
all of this in Cloud CDW,
but you have to do it manually.
And so the tools
that we're working on
will help to automate
a lot of this,
and over time add
machine learning
to it so that it can start to
suggest the mappings to you.
Over on the right-hand side
here are the target schemas.
So just as we recognize health
care data in its native formats
as first class citizens, we
also recognize certain schemas
that are typically
used for health care
analysis as first
class citizens as well.
And starting at the
top there is FHIR.
So if you're looking for a way
to start converting to FHIR,
converting your data to FHIR,
this gives you a path to that.
The second one listed here
is OMOP, the OMOP common data
model, which Greg
Klebanov is going to talk
a bit more about in a moment.
And then underneath i2b2,
and CDISC, and frankly,
any other schema, because we all
know that many health systems
or for certain analyses,
there are always
schemas that already exist that
people need to continue using,
at least for a while.
So you don't need to change
the approach you're taking
in order to leverage Cloud CDW.
So right now FHIR and OMOP exist
as target schemas within Cloud
CDW, as well as
the custom schemas.
They exist as well.
And then we'll be adding
CDISC and i2b2 over time.
Of course, you set up your data
harmonization rules, and then
everything changes.
Your source changes.
Maybe your source
schema changes.
Epic releases a new version.
Cerner releases a new version.
Your vocabulary has changed,
because they're always
being updated.
Or your target schema changes.
Everything changes
along the way.
And so you need to be
watching for those changes.
And so around this
data harmonization
and all these transformations
is the framework
to enable you to
monitor and to manage
lifecycle changes within this.
And included within
that, something
that we're starting
to work on now
is understanding when data
is exceptioned, but also what
limits an exception you will
allow through with warnings
versus what things
will really alert you,
because you need to do
something about that.
And we're leveraging the
concepts of statistical process
control, which is very common
within the manufacturing
industry in order to help
drive that decision making
around when to alert, when to
warn, when to let pass through.
And the lifecycle
management becomes critical,
because from a data provenance
perspective, when you're
looking to try and
track back the data,
then you also need to understand
where that data came from.
And so understanding
which version of the data
harmonization was in
place at that time
and exactly what that
transformation was, where
the sources of data
were that came,
that becomes really important.
I mentioned the public
data sets before.
We now have over 100 public
data sets available on BigQuery
that you can just integrate
into any analysis,
join as tables into any analysis
that you are doing on BigQuery.
These are some of
the health care
and life science ones available.
There's a bunch of
biomedical data sets
that we're bringing on as part
of the NIH strides initiative.
And then there's a fair bit
of Medicare and Medicaid
data from CMS.
But we're also
always in the process
of adding more data sets.
And right now my focus
is trying to ensure
that we add more social
determinants of health data
sets that will help
with the analysis
that you're trying to do
within your populations.
Once you've harmonized
all that data,
what do you want to do with it?
Maybe you just want to create
some kind of dashboard,
some kinds of analytics that
will help you understand things
like the longitudinal
patient record,
or maybe you need to create
analytics that are portable.
So I think about defining
cohorts of patients
in the same way that
I think about needing
to enable clinicians to do those
definitions in terms that they
understand.
So not looking at the
detailed fields and saying,
ah, I want to select
on this field,
and I need to join it with
that thing over there.
But rather enabling a user
interface that clinicians
can say, look, these are
my inclusion criteria
and these are my
exclusion criteria,
and be able to leverage
common definitions for things
like certain
conditions, leveraging
clinical quality
metric definitions,
leveraging other
common definitions
that are out there
in our industry.
And so you'll be able to
create your cohort definitions,
and underneath these
will be made portable
so that you can then apply those
cohorts definitions to any data
set that could be
enabled within FHIR.
So this becomes really
powerful for you,
because it helps to
protect your investment.
As well as cohort
definitions, you
can think of query definitions
and metric definitions
in the same way.
So we'll be couching
behind the scenes
these definitions within FHIR.
And of course, we'll
help you get to FHIR.
So that that way, if you
bring on another data set,
all you need to do is
realign it to FHIR,
and then apply that
definition on top of it.
And that could be a query.
That could be a metric.
That could be a cohort.
And over time, we'll also enable
you to share these definitions
with others as well.
And so that too
helps, particularly
in the research
world, particularly
as you're looking at doing
more collaboration with others
in your field.
Another reason why people
want to bring all of this data
together-- and I've spent quite
a bit of time this week talking
to several people about this--
is in order to use it
for machine learning,
in order to use it
either to train a model
or, more often right now,
to be able to infer data,
to be able to predict data
using somebody else's model.
Well, we'll meet
you where you are.
We have a range of different
machine learning tools,
APIs, and techniques
that can help you.
And all of these work
directly on top of BigQuery
and on top of our Cloud CDW.
Over on your left, are the ones
that require more engineering.
So things like TensorFlow or
being able to leverage Spark
ML, Cloud CMLE.
In the middle are some
of the predefined models
that we have available.
So for example, our
Natural Language API,
our Video Intelligence API,
and also our Translation API.
And then over on the
right, BigQuery ML,
which so far is primarily for
classification and regressions,
but over time may expand as
well in its capabilities.
So if you want to train machine
learning models, bring it on.
Bring it into
Cloud CDW, and then
have all of these
different tools
available for you to do that.
Now, if you're trying to apply
somebody else's models on top
of the data in Cloud CDW,
we'll help you do that, too.
So our framework will let you
invoke other machine learning
APIs as well to make
those predictions.
Finally, you've done that.
And in some cases,
that's it, right?
You're using that
data internally.
In other cases, particularly
in some research cases,
you'll want to deidentify
that data in order
to make it available
to researchers.
And so that the
Deidentification API
is the first step on the way to
being able to share those data
sets more broadly with
other researchers.
We have other things in
the works there as well,
but this is what's
available right now.
And this Deidentification works
not just on structured data.
That's relatively easy.
But also on imaging data.
So if there is PHI burned
into the medical image
pixels, which there often is.
And it also works on
unstructured clinical notes
as well.
And in addition, on
the structured data,
if you already have
some deidentified data,
we can now present back to you
the risk of reidentification
of that data as well so that
you can understand where
the risk lies on the spectrum.
I talked a little bit about
this actually last year
when I said I think we'd run
three datathons at that point
on GCP and had, I think, another
six coming up in the next year.
Well, that proliferated.
They bred like bunnies.
And we've actually supported
now 11 over the last year.
These are a great way to get
your team's direct experience
of using GCP with
health care data.
They're held around the world.
If anybody would like
more information,
come up and see us at the end.
But this is essentially
a little package
that allows organizers
to host health care
datathon in an appropriate
environment for that.
And so if you want to host a
datathon, come up and see us.
Just bring your data
set to us, and we're
happy to help get
that set up with you.
Or if you are interested
in attending them or having
one of your team attend
one, let us know as well.
Typically, what happens is
over the course of a weekend,
everybody gets together
and really blacks
out clinical data science
on top of BigQuery
and on top using
data science tools.
So with that, I'd
like to hand over
to Josh, who's going to talk
about on the data ingestion
process how you take that
data, X12 data in this case,
and convert it into FHIR.
And with Josh is Alen as well.
Thank you.
JOSH SIEGEL: Thank
you, Marianne.
Is everybody excited
to take a look
at a deep dive at the clinical
data hiding in X12 ANSI format?
[CHEERING]
Yes.
All right.
So as some of you may know, Care
Cloud is an electronic practice
management and electronic
medical records system platform
entirely hosted in the cloud.
And one of the reasons
why we're here with you
guys today is we've been a
technology partner working
with the GCP team,
particularly on the Healthcare
API for the better
part of the last year.
So going through the
various alpha phases.
And one of the things
that we've been
able to do that we want
to demonstrate for you
today, as Marianne mentioned,
all of the great power
and insight that you can
gain from your data having it
formatted in FHIR and having
it prepared for prediction,
this is an example of
how that can be done,
and frankly, how easy
it looks once you've
taken the time to build that
out in your own systems.
So how many people in
here are familiar with X12
and have dealt with
that as a data format?
Show of hands.
OK.
Not too many people.
We'll dive into
what it's used for,
but primarily, this is the
way that electronic practice
management systems, medical
records systems, big pharmacy
benefit management companies
transact between each other.
This is a 40-year-old
interoperability format.
We were both born in 1979.
That's why I like X12.
But it's in use
quite prevalent early
across all of the big payers.
And what that means
is a lot of the data
that we want to
analyze longitudinally,
especially when you think
about the clinical perspective,
is locked up in these really
old archival data formats.
So FHIR coming around,
and now with FHIR
v4, we're standardizing
on a normative model that
is going to allow us
to essentially continue
with backward compatibility,
have this normative format
that we can do analysis on.
So Care Cloud,
because of the way
that we service our
existing provider customers,
already has invested a lot
of technology and know-how
into translating very
specific, detailed data,
in this case bidirectionally.
So we're talking about fully
interoperable, bidirectional
semantic translation
of data from
the different-- the
various components of X12
messages into the
equivalent FHIR resource.
That's a mouthful,
so we're going
to actually pop into a
demonstration to kind of show
how easy it is once it's
been put into practice.
Alen Pulido here is our
technical lead whose team
did all of the development.
So he's up here
making it happen.
So this is our console.
We're announcing here
at the conference
the beta of this as part of the
beta for the Healthcare API.
So this is going to be available
through the marketplace,
or working with us,
we can offer this
as a managed service
or a SaaS offering.
But we're going to go through
how simple the configuration is
to go from an X12 archive into
FHIR resources in the Google
Healthcare API.
So we're going to start off.
We're going to go through
and configure a tenant.
And if you think about
the various different ways
that X12 can be managed
inside an organization,
you might have dozens or
hundreds of different X12
definitions for a single
message type in a large pay
organization.
So in this case,
we're going to say
we have options for the
sources during the beta.
GCS is obviously our favorite.
But if you're looking to move
into the Google Healthcare API
from somebody else, those
are available as well.
If we pop over, it's
as simple as basically
configuring the bucket that you
want to pull the data out of
and targeting your FHIR server.
In this case, it's the
Google Healthcare API.
I'll do another quick
survey before we
kick this next part off.
How many of you have
your own FHIR servers
or have a team of
engineers back home
that are trying to build
your own FHIR solution?
OK.
Even if you're not, go back
home and tell everybody
to stop doing that.
I'll testify for a second
from just personal experience.
We went through a lot
of the open source
projects, evaluated
nearly all of them,
went so far as to even look
at developing our own cloud
hosted FHIR server in-house.
Really, when you look at the
amount of raw engineering
that it takes to get
that all the way through,
take advantage of the
work that Kurt is doing.
That team is really strong.
They're really committed to
maintaining the standard.
And frankly, the service
is really performant.
As we've gotten through the
various phases of the alpha,
it's really at a place
where it's enterprise
grade, production strength.
You can really pump a
lot of data through it.
So we're going to
go ahead and trigger
a sweep of all of the,
in this case, 837 claims.
So, well, we talked
about how many
people had ever seen an 837.
So we're going to give you
a sneak peek at what that
actually looks like.
So if you're a COBOL programmer,
if you like mainframes,
this is what we love.
But locked in here is all of
the valuable procedures that
were performed on the patient,
the related diagnoses that
were used as the supporting
clinical rationale for why
that procedure
was performed, all
of the patient
detailed demographics.
It's a very good dense
data format 40 years ago
when you really needed to
transact between mainframes.
And frankly, there's
billions of dollars
of existing
investment in keeping
this format operational.
And this is, frankly,
the backbone of the way
that we process medical
claims in the US.
So if we go back,
again, thinking
about the power of
the way GCP allows
us to build data
pipelines and do
these types of
transformations, we
can do this at batch or
in a streaming fashion.
So as these X12 messages
are being generated,
we can translate
them on the fly.
Now, if you flip--
roll this forward.
Now, as more and more of
our industry is trend--
standardizing on FHIR as
the primary data format,
this type of
semantic translation
allows us to take
the FHIR resource
and translate it
now back into X12,
which is the format that
your mainframes are typically
going to be processing.
So we can pop in.
And we call it a human
readable X12 message.
And that means
that, really, you're
an analyst that specializes in
looking at these types of data.
But breaking it out by the
various loops and segments,
you can see the nested
hierarchy the way
this data gets generated.
And again, we're talking about
that full fidelity capability
of translating it on the wire.
We have another legacy format.
If you guys are familiar with
this, this is a CMS-1500.
But again, you think
about the power
of being able to have this
type of semantic mapping.
You can just talk about
processing images.
We can generate the
CMS-1500 claim form directly
from what would have been an
electronic claims submission.
Now, the real power
and where this
flows into the
clinical data analysis
is being able to get into
the FHIR resource itself.
So if you're thinking about
modern development languages,
modern programming
techniques, most folks
are not going to be
building those applications
and those capabilities against
that native X12 format.
But there is a semantic mapping.
And there is a way
of representing it
as a FHIR resource.
In this case, we can go down
and take a look at the--
we'll take a look
at the diagnosis,
or do you want to look
at the-- we've got that.
OK.
The claim ID.
So again, we're talking
about bringing this
from a legacy or an
archival claim storage.
FHIR is really good at being
able to identify resources
across systems.
And if you're bringing something
out of a legacy system,
maintaining the identity
integrity from the system that
generated it, and as you move
it out to the FHIR server
being able to reference it
without having to copy it.
And for all of us
here, as true believers
in clinical and clinical
data analysis and health
care IT in general, this allows
us, as Marianne mentioned,
as we're publishing data sets,
as we're evolving our ability
to make this data
useful and available,
we can leave that data in the
resident FHIR server, where
the entity that's responsible
for managing it is,
and we can reference
it through FHIR.
And so that's really
our goal here.
It's to maintain that
identity and integrity.
So the other great part is now,
if you think about the way EMRs
and everybody are building
the supporting information
clinically, that all
gets represented in FHIR
as a procedure code
and a diagnosis code.
And they're mapped here so
that you have the linked
diagnosis with all
of the procedures
that were performed
on the patient.
And now, in our
case, I know we've
mentioned a few other EMRs,
but some EMRs out there
are generating
their clinical data
in a FHIR compatible format.
So as these things
evolve, this is really
where we can start to find
out things totally new.
Maybe there's a
propensity to not
go to your follow-up appointment
after your last claim was
denied.
Now, if you're putting
these data together,
you can start to map out
how patients were treated
against how the financial
information was actually
transacted between the patient
and their insurance company.
We'll give you a little--
OK.
We're good there.
We'll hop back to the slides.
The joys of AV.
OK.
So the last bit, we have to
have a ubiquitous market texture
slide or it doesn't seem like
anybody's doing anything.
So the idea is that all of these
pipelines are built in GCP.
We're talking about using
the same powerful tools
that Marianne mentioned.
That's everything
that transacted it,
going from GCS as the
source data format,
moving through Dataflow.
You can take the picture, but
you need the Edison Engine
in the middle there to actually
do the semantic translation.
But this really
does work at scale.
We've tested this
into the millions
of messages generating.
We did an interesting
conversion with a data
set that we might
potentially open source
where we created 4.3 million
FHIR resource bundles out
of the NPPES data set that's
publicly available in BigQuery.
And it ran in about 15 minutes.
And that's in a single
Dataflow pipeline.
These are really
powerful tools that
are really ready to
handle our scale of data.
In this case now, all of
the data that we've ingested
is prepared and
ready in the FHIR API
to be leveraged by all
of the other capabilities
that folks have
been talking about.
So all of this is key.
So what we're asking
here, coming out of this
if you have any
questions or you'd
like to participate in the beta,
if you can follow up with any
of us after the
program, we're looking
for folks that are potentially
looking to leverage GKE
On-Prem, because all of this is
being deployed in Kubernetes.
So you can either
host it in your GCP
project in your own
Kubernetes container.
We can host in
Kubernetes for you also.
But we think that a lot of
big health care institutions
are going to be
keen on trying out
GKE On-Prem in their own
VMware infrastructure.
We think that's going to
have some pretty significant
mechanical advantages, too,
to have the data translation
process as close to the
archival data as possible.
And then, as you think about
moving out to the cloud
and moving from those on-prem
or co-locations out to GCP,
that data is already
in GCP prepped for you
in the Healthcare API.
So with that, I'll hand
it back to Marianne.
MARIANNE SLIGHT:
Thank you very much.
So that's showing a
real example of how
you can use GCP to convert
that kind of data to FHIR.
Can you-- I don't know
how we're doing this.
Great.
And so, actually, I think we
want to go back to the slides
first.
Sorry.
And so next up is Greg Klebanov,
CTO of Odysseus Data Services.
We talked about OMOP as being
one of those standard schemas.
Greg's going to talk
more about that.
Thank you, Greg.
GREGORY KLEBANOV:
Hello, everybody.
I'm Greg Klebanov.
I'm the the CTO at
Odysseus Data Services.
I can't really see you,
but I know you're there
and you can see me.
So today, I will demo a
tool that was developed
and has been maintained by
the open-science, open-source
community called OHDSI.
And before I even dive into this
demo, I'd like to put this tool
and what we do in
the context of OHDSI
as an open-science community.
So OHDSI is
pronounced as Odyssey.
It's spelled O-H-D-S-I. It
stands for Observational Health
Data Sciences and Informatics.
It's, again, an international
open-science, open-source
community that is
focused on enabling
standardized, reproducible,
scalable, observational data
analytics across the world.
And what I'd like to
stress is that OHDSI
is an open-source, open-science
community, meaning it's public.
It's open.
It's international.
And anybody can join.
Anybody can contribute.
And anybody can use any of the
tools and standards and methods
that are developed
by this community.
It's worth mentioning that
Columbia University is
a coordinating center
across the world.
As you can see, OHDSI
is a global community.
It spans multiple countries,
multiple continents,
and today you can
see the statistics.
It's growing quite nicely.
And we work very closely with
our partners and collaborators
in the US, in
Europe, and in Asia,
including South Korea and China.
So the mission of OHDSI is to
really improve public health
by enabling better health
care decisions based
on evidence produced from
real world data sets.
And so one of the--
apologies for that.
So OHDSI, again, is an
open-science, open-source
community that enables key
open standards, including
the standard that's
called OMOP CDM.
Common Data Model, that's
what CDM stands for.
And the latest
version, version 6--
you can see it on the screen--
is quite mature, quite
nicely developed.
So in addition to a
common data model,
OHDSI also enabled a set
of standardized medical
vocabularies and a set
of standardized tools.
And one of those tools is ATLAS.
And I'll show it to you today.
But before I dive
into ATLAS, I'd
just like to maybe talk a
little bit about the data
journey of how this data gets
into data analytics platforms
like ATLAS.
So data sets, what kind of
data sets are we working with?
We're working with
clinical data sets,
or what we call
real world data that
comes from different types of
organizations that come from--
well, they could be
medical insurance claims,
or electronic medical records.
They could be a lab results,
survey data, clinical trial
data, chart reviews, and so on.
So any types of
data that is coming
from a clinical utilization
of drugs and treatments,
we essentially need
to process and convert
into a standardized
format called OMOP CDM.
So what's nice
about OMOP CDM, what
creates a single standardized
way of saving data,
so that data scientists
or researchers only
have to design their
query once, and then they
can go and see that this query
is going to run on any OMOP CDM
database across the world.
And I'm really excited
to say that we added--
so ATLAS, and many
other tools in OHDSI,
they support, I believe, close
to nine different data sets--
I'm sorry-- databases.
And I'm really excited
to say that we also
now provide support for GCP
platform, including big data--
BigQuery-- I'm sorry--
BigQuery database.
So what you see on the
screen is essentially
a simplified architecture
of how we process
data to convert into OMOP CDM.
And we've successfully
converted data sets,
actually pretty large
data sets utilizing
Dataproc and Apache Spark.
So it's also worth
mentioning that the data sets
that we're working with are
very, very large in size.
They can be very, very large.
Medical claims data tend to
grow in data aggregators,
such as IBM MarketScan
Databases tend
to be over 200 million patients
in size for a single database.
So it would typically
mean tens of billions
of records that need to
be processed and converted
into OMOP CDM.
I'm also very excited to say
that OHDSI ATLAS, which is--
oh, I don't know
what happened here.
OHDSI ATLAS, that
is probably one
of the most common and popular
tools in the OHDSI community,
also now supports BigQuery
database underneath.
And I'll give you a little demo
of that tool in the second.
So ATLAS is a tool that
was produced and is
produced and developed
by the OHDSI community.
So my company,
Odysseus Data Services,
is one of the most
active contributors
in developing this tool.
And ATLAS is a tool
that was designed
to enable research
of data scientists
with an ability to design
complex analysis studies,
and then execute those studies
on the top of the OMOP CDM
database.
I need some magic here.
Great.
So bear with me one second.
So what you see right
now on the screen
is the latest release
of OHDSI ATLAS tool.
And the tool is actually
quite mature at this point.
It's quite sophisticated.
It offers multiple
quiet nice features,
including a full database
level characteristics,
which you will find like--
this thing is on.
I don't see the mouse.
Here we go.
It's called ACHILLES.
So ACHILLES is a full database
level characterization
of your data set.
So you can imagine that
before a scientist even
begins to design their
study and research,
they would like to know what's
available in a database.
And this information should
be coming from ACHILLES.
So ACHILLES allows
you as a researcher
to see data stratified into
different types of dimensions
that are available in
OMOP CDM, including it
will give you dashboard
information, demographics
information, visit information,
conditions information,
procedures, drug exposures,
measurements, and so on.
So it's for any researcher.
It's very, very, very
easy to come to ACHILLES
and just look up if this
specific database contains
information about
a condition/disease
or a drug of interest
before they even run
a complex analytics encoding.
So another secret
sauce in OMOP CDM
is a set of standardized
medical vocabulary.
As Marianne
previously said, drugs
can be quoted in
many different ways.
And different drug norms
exist, and OCD, the vocabulary
of this.
So one of the most
fundamental standards
and decisions that
OHDSI made is that they
decided to standardize.
So what our team
is actually doing,
they bring together multiple
medical vocabularies,
and they standardize on a
single representation of a drug,
on a single representation
of a condition,
so that when data is being
converted from raw data
into OMOP CDM, data
is being converted
into a standardized
representation
of that condition or a drug.
So here, in ATLAS, you'll
be able, as a researcher,
to search and browse
medical vocabularies.
So cohorts.
Any mature analytical tool
offers today a cohort builder,
a cohort designer of some sort.
And so ATLAS is probably one
of the most sophisticated tools
that has been developed
in the industry.
So it allows you as a researcher
to design very sophisticated
cohort information.
Not only you can
design a cohort--
and I've got some
samples there I'm
going to show you in a second--
but you can also--
as you design your
cohorts, you obviously
take advantage of standardized
medical vocabularies,
and then you can execute some
basic statistics immediately
by utilizing this cohort.
So for example, I've
generated some accounts.
I designed a cohort that
is meaningful to me.
So it's ibuprofen being taken
by a male over 40 years old.
And I ran it against
the CMS data set.
So SynPUF is a
synthetic data set.
It's a representation of
CMS data, claims data.
And I can immediately see
that my cohort resulted
in 170,000 patients that
would fit the cohort.
And I immediately see how
my filters, my criteria
limited a cohort
selection at the end.
So cohorts are the building
blocks in any data analytics
tool.
And again, the user can see this
is running against a BigQuery
database.
And then it gets
more complicated.
Of course, as scientists
continue their research,
they would like to know
not only how many patients
do exist in a specific
data set, but they
would like to get a
full characterization
of that cohort.
Characterization
meaning take this cohort
and stratify it by different
dimensions, by different--
that exist in the
OMOP CDM data set.
So for example, in this
case, this specific case,
I actually took two cohorts--
one aspirin users and one
ibuprofen users-- and I
put them against one another.
For some reason I
can't scroll again.
Here we go.
So as you can see, I can
now characterize my cohort
by different criterias that I'm
able as a researcher to select.
Then as one of the
latest features
that was added in ATLAS
is the treatment pathway.
So especially--
treatment pathways
are very important when, for
example, an oncology patient
is going through a treatment.
And it's very often when
oncology patient is going
through a treatment, they go
through a multiple specific
predefined treatment pathway.
So in this specific
case, actually, it's
not talking about oncology.
It's talking about diabetes 2.
But you can see a
pathway of treatment
of different patients, of
how they go from drug one
into drug two and to drug
three throughout their journey.
Incident rates.
Basically incident rates
provide exactly what it means.
It's the incident
of certain outcomes
in the set of cohort patients.
So in this specific
case, it's incidence of--
I'm not sure what that means.
I'm sorry.
I can see it here.
So you can also see a
more complicated analysis
of estimation and
prediction analysis.
Estimation is, again, a relative
risk of something happening
based on your data set.
And the more complicated
case just recently
added is a patient level
prediction analysis.
So patient level
prediction, basically,
is the probability of
something happening
for a very specific
type of patient,
the probability of
developing certain conditions
in the future.
So patient level
prediction is just
an example of, again, a
personalized treatment
that is possible today to
develop for different patients.
So I know I have
very limited time.
And ATLAS, as you can see,
is a pretty extensive tool.
Again, I'm really excited to
say that now ATLAS supports
BigQuery as a database.
And the last words, I would
like to say that, again,
whatever you saw today,
ATLAS is an open source tool.
So anybody can come.
Anybody can join the community,
contribute, or use it.
And I thank you
for your attention.
MARIANNE SLIGHT: Great.
Thank you very much, Greg.
[APPLAUSE]
So to wrap up--
maybe.
There we go.
My closing message
for you, really,
is start bringing your
health care and life science
data onto Google Cloud.
Start thinking about the
analytics that you want to do.
Start thinking about
the harmonizations
that you need to do and
where you want that data.
Do you want it in
FHIR persisted on GCP,
as Care Cloud has talked about?
Do you want to bring it into
a specific target schema
to enable collaboration
with others,
as Greg has talked about?
Most importantly, you
can get started now,
but plan ahead for
scale, and think
about how some of the
tools that we're building
might help you do that
kind of data alignment.
[MUSIC PLAYING]